I'm a lot more gentle with myself and
nice to myself and I think I don't know
something's changed this year for sure
Cara delevingne's loving her new life
after getting sober the actress is
vogue's cover star for its April issue
and inside she opens up about some dark
moments from the past year all of it
leading to rehab and a 12-step program
something's changed this year for sure
and I 2023 is a lot but I I I'm very
happy as Cara tells it if I was
continuing to go down the road I was I
would either end up dead or doing
something really really stupid
public concerns started around last
year's Met Gala where Cara's Ensemble
raised eyebrows she reveals she got
blackout then traveled to her
grandmother's funeral the next day it
was horrible I think my twenties were
brilliant but that was a lot of things
that I can't I suppose that like my life
there were just different things I
wanted to focus on and um you know I
think that was a part of me that still
felt like I was insecure in my teenage
years and questioning and a bit of like
self-doubt all the time Cara's spiral
reached a Breaking Point in September
concern was growing among fans after
some alarming photos one snap showing
Cara not wearing shoes at the airport
she says sometimes you need a reality
check so in a way those pictures were
something to be grateful for Cara
entered rehab for addiction where she
found a community and it made a huge
difference it's beautiful that said Carr
confesses there's been ups and downs in
her next chapter and she's had to dig
deeper because change doesn't happen
overnight
another life transition this year saying
goodbye to her 20s I think for turning
30 there was a lot Sunny that clicked
that is a real thing about women being
in their Prime in their 30s I just don't
care anymore I'm a lot more gentle with
myself and nice to myself and I I'm very
happy to be 30. I did find 20s more
difficult than everyone says that they
are and I'm like it's the best years of
your life I was like it's still kind of
rough back in the Vogue profile Cara
shares the Insight she's carrying into
her next era I always thought that the
work needs to be done when the times are
bad but actually the work needs to be
done when they're good it's never going
to be fixed or fully healed but I'm okay
with that and that's the difference
[Music]
thank you